so we've been talking about the
us-mexico border wall and immigration
and the so-called crisis that doesn't
exist at this point for months but in a
real bigger sense release four years
since Donald Trump started his campaign
for the presidency and we've seen a
significant goalposts move one that I
call off the field and into the parking
lot which started with Mexico's going to
pay for the wall and it'll be all nearly
2,000 miles of us-mexico border that
went to well taxpayers are going to pay
for the entire wall and we're still
gonna have 2,000 miles of it too
taxpayers are going to pay for 55 miles
of bollards for 1.3 billion in Trump's
not going to shut down government over
it that gave way late last week to this
is a crisis and Donald Trump is
declaring a national emergency the point
of all of this is to create a pretext
for Donald Trump to commandeer money for
the us-mexico border wall from the US
military and to use the military and
construction powers to just force the
wall to be built circumventing the will
of both the American people and of the
House and Senate neither of which is
into authorizing Donald Trump to
actually do this now we've got to break
this down into its component parts to
even have a shot at understanding the
political implications here number one
there is no illegal immigration crisis
and there is no national emergency here
the real emergency is Donald Trump being
President of the United States and using
such mechanisms as national emergencies
to commandeer funding for projects
Congress won't fund this is disgusting
and it cannot be allowed now let's go
through each talking point in defense of
what Donald Trump is doing one defense
of Donald Trump declaring a national
emergency is national emergencies have
been used before there have been dozens
of national emergencies declared it's
really not a big deal to declare a
national emergency
this is ridiculous the reality is that
yes national emergencies have been
declared before but those national
emergencies were in concert with what
Congress authorized funds for and wanted
to do right the Pres
in allegiance with what Congress wanted
declares a national emergency to
expedite certain decisions or to get
money certain places that Congress
agrees with doing this is the opposite
okay
Congress has declined to fund the wall
multiple times and Donald Trump is
declaring a national emergency to get a
rep excuse me to get around Congress to
circumvent Congress that's not what has
happened in the past that defense is
bogus defense number two this is finally
going to get the wall built in
accordance with what Donald Trump
promised during his campaign wrong
during his campaign Donald Trump's
promise was that they would build 1954
miles of wall that's the entire
us-mexico border and importantly that
Mexico would pay for it this will divert
if it works eight billion total dollars
for the wall and it'll come one point
three seven five billion from the deal
that was made last week by Congress to
keep government open three point six
billion will be taken from military
construction including hospitals two
point five billion will come from the
Department of Defense money meant for
countering drug activity and then the
Treasury will provide six hundred
million dollars so this is going to
maybe build a couple of hundred miles
most optimistically it will take years
likely to the end of Trump's presidency
and there is not even the remote
possibility that 1954 miles of border
wall are going to be built I mean like
don't even dream about it but then we
get to what really is the most important
underlying issue here which is there
simply no crisis legally we don't know
what's going to happen Pat there are
going to be lawsuits Democrats have
tactics to stop this but my hope is that
in a court of law
the Trump administration has to actually
prove that there is a crisis and I don't
know how you do it between ten years of
reduced border crossings year after year
the low criminality of undocumented
immigrants the net outflow of immigrants
to Mexico if you are the Trump
administration Pat how do you go to
court and prove that there's even a
crisis here worthy of an emergency
exactly based on the timeline of events
and lack of evidence to suggest that
this is an
national emergency I think there is a
good chance that the court strike this
down but who knows if it goes all the
way up to the Supreme Court
well Trump's buddies Cavanaugh and
Gorsuch are sitting on there so maybe
they'll let his emergency slide through
but there's also a case we made though
if that happens then that's not even so
bad because the next Democratic
president could say hey I think that gun
violence or I think that climate changes
the national emergency and we have to
declare one for those issues too that's
what's been discussed and I do think
that that is a little bit risky but it
is an it is a valid question at least to
be bringing up what does this open up
the door to do most importantly we have
Trump's own words saying he didn't need
to do this I mean here he is from his
declaration speech saying he actually
didn't need to do this but on the wall
they skimmed so I did I was successful
in that sense but I want to do it faster
I could do the wall over a longer period
of time I didn't need to do this but I'd
rather do it much faster and I don't
have to do it for the election I've
already done a lot of wall if it's an
emergency then you need to do it that's
the whole point of emergencies they are
emergencies that need action and most
importantly if it were an emergency
Trump would have done it two years ago
when the problem was worse even by
today's standards than right now if you
could do the wall over a longer period
of time by definition this is not an
emergency and of course Trump is not
behaving like someone who's dealing with
an emergency immediately heading to one
of his golf clubs played a few rounds of
golf was photographed at the omelet
station grabbing an omelet after or
before golfing who knows here is the
most important issue constitutionally if
you're a small government conservative
you should be furious with Donald Trump
because this if allowed is a massive
expansion of government power and of
presidential power because Congress is
meant to be a check on the president if
the president goes around congressional
opposition to build the wall it should
be the nightmare of small government
conservatives and of course
the midst of all of this we see that
Roger stone was in contact with
WikiLeaks we see that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders has been pulled into the Trump
Russia investigation we see Robert
Muller recommending up to 24 years in
prison for Trump's campaign chairman
Paul Manafort potentially an effective
life sentence on him it's all closing in
around Trump he's getting more and more
erratic and in terms of how this will
impact Trump's followers my guess is not
much at all they've already decided on
intuition that the wall is good and the
wall is right they will create post hoc
rationalizations for why the national
emergency is the right thing to do
don't even waste your breath trying to
convince them to change their mind about
Donald Trump